Any of this stuff and how do you know?
I mean it's a.
you're talking about retroviruses.
That's an incredibly intense subject to
be researching.
There's a lot involved and understanding
it.
So understandably people rely on folks
like you.
We rely on someone who has done the work
and is a,
is a professor and when we hear a guy
like you saying that HIV doesn't cause
aids,
that's like,
it's very confusing.
There's,
I'm sure your life is filled with
controversy.
I mean,
what,
what is an average day like for you as
far as like hate mail?
Do you get a lot of hate mail?
Get a lot of me,
but he does actually minority really?
There's a lot of guys saying.
She said all of a suspected something is
or can you tell me?
Can you explain me?
What should I do?
Should I take anti bio tugs?
I feel horrible and I give them answers.
My answers not going to tell him why I
give these senses.
It's not just
no.
For people who don't understand your,
your argument.
I mean in a,
in a,
in a paraphrasing sort of way is that
these,
it's,
it's illicit drug use,
it's like a email nitrate and crystal
meth and that is what's destroying the
immune systems of these people and then
HIV shows up because their immune system
is diminished.
Is that a fair assessment,
diminished or not?
It is just the chance that you might be
positive or not.
It's like with all my copd,
you know,
you can catch it or not,
but of course if you are what they used
to be at least in first line of aids
patients,
the gay person,
gay guys a day had hunters have in,
in,
in the gay liberation days,
hundreds of dates and so that's like
Mike Michael Collection.
If you could detect or get in contact,
any mid contract,
whatever,
contact with lots of people,
you pick up what's available on the
market [inaudible] you see,
and that's where my Kolbe collectors,
so they had this Michael,
but it hit all others tools.
They had hepatitis B bows and they had
to immediately and so HIV is a virus is
a virus,
is it?
It's one of the most harmless type of
fibrosis would be no,
that's why we only discovered them
really well in the lab or worked in them
in the last 10 years.
So how could it be possible that no one
else believes this,
that the scientific community sort of
looks down on,
on your,
your assessment of this and,
and,
and what,
what is your,
what's the argument?
Daddy's.
I think much politics behind it.
You see the was hunters is we used to be
called,
still called those who are looking for
viruses doing something or another they,
they apply this to find something to get
the for,
to do something.
If they do something bad then they're
important.
You know what I mean?
So if they,
if they are harmless,
they are not so important.
Same.
Okay.
You study your harmless is telling me
what else is happening here.
So then we tried that in the sixties and
fifties.
It was popular then seventies that this
might cause cancer.
You may have heard about this,
but it was cancer poke come,
but it was Kansas Coe and we tried very
hard.
This is why I came to this country from
Germany.
Yeah,
that was a hot item.
Said,
okay.
We find that
as an example,
I'm a human papilloma virus can turn
into cervical cancer,
right?
I mean you can catch a virus,
something one type or the theory goes
and then if you.
If left unchecked,
it grows into cervical cancer as an
example.
Right?
Is that what you're talking about?
What they clean,
but what it really does,
it makes a word.
It's why it's called Papilloma is
another word for word.
What to say,
what did.
Maybe 30 years later you get cancer when
they come in with a long lead in period,
you can already something.
Something is.
It doesn't.
It doesn't add up.
Why was this not slow?
They are not that complicated.
They infect you.
Now all they want to do is replicating
what they produce their own.
They don't wait 10 or 20 years for
something to happen.
There was.
Wouldn't you admit though,
if you look in.
I,
I watched a lot of people die in the
eighties in New York and,
and a number of them were gay,
but from Wiki,
yes,
that was the first still lift,
the made sure,
sure.
But,
but here's,
here's what was interesting is that most
of them were dying from it from very
similar symptoms if you went there,
in fact,
majority of aids,
and you can correct me where I'm wrong
here,
but the majority of aids patients die of
starvation.
A,
it's very difficult for them to hold
food,
to retain food.
That was really when you went to the
wards and I did,
you'd see all these aids patients and
they were terribly skinny.
And actually what happened was,
yes,
the virus would,
uh,
would destroy your immune system and
you'd be exposed to you to get car
pullman car,
Posey Sarcoma,
which was a big,
these rare skin cancers that only old
people get an all kinds of awful
diseases.
I mean,
I watched people with these terrible
rashes.
They didn't know what.
You're not a doctor.
I'm not a doctor at all.
I'm just an actor,
man.
I don't know.
I know nothing.
I was just,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I've read a lot of innovation over.
You said you went to.
Yeah,
I've read a lot about it and correct me
by the way.
I'm a layman so,
but,
but I,
I'm,
I'm just,
I'm going to get to a question.
It's not a,
it's not a point of view,
it's a question,
but I'm.
One of the things that,
that,
that there was clearly in their
bloodstream,
when you get tested for what they'd call
HIV,
they're not seeing the virus.
What you get tested for and what shows
up on your test is antibodies to the
virus.
Right?
Very important point.
You know,
it's just as opposite as you could get
other files antibody against it.
Neutralizing and stopping.
And Kenny.
Exactly.
That is a vaccine that is nature's and
men's.
Mankind's only protection against
violence is a vaccine
for yourself or induced by somebody.
However though,
yes,
the body mounts a defense with
antibiotics.
What,
what the theory,
and I,
and I'll just add to this what the
theory was that what happens is it's
such an onslaught on your immune system.
The immune system eventually gives up
and cannot produce enough antibodies.
Your immune system gets killed.
Along comes David Ho with you and I know
you know the name Dr.
That's right.
And Yeah Man of the year times man was
also middle of the year,
but the devil's in the 30 to a Nazi.
But,
but,
but having said that doctor,
there are a lot of people that took
protease inhibitors and I know him and
by the way,
when they were dying,
they sold all their stuff because they
were going to be gone in a month.
And Lo and behold,
proteosome inhibitor is keep people
alive.
I mean I've seen this.
So the question becomes if protease
inhibitors,
which by the way now you still have to
use to have to take,
as you know,
a bunch of pills.
Now it's down to four or five pills a
day.
There are a lot of people living with
HIV that the argument goes and I,
at least from what I've seen would have
been dead and now are living very normal
lives and how do you explain that?
That's what they obviously play,
but look at the people who don't take
these tugs.
World Health Organization,
the Centers for disease control say $35,
million of them at least on this planet.
Probably even more.
This is 30 percent of the African in
America.
We have a million.
These million,
that million in American HIV positive
was there in 85 is still here.
Why didn't they die?
Or they did that though.
A lot of people died in the ACF.
Still a million.
He the numbers the same as it
originally.
Any million Americans.
Yes,
there would be certain years later it
wouldn't be the same rule yet,
but there will be replaced in part.
Well isn't that because people were
catching it more and more.
I mean you,
you.
In other words,
you had it already in in 85 when it
bites mission 1 million were positive.
Now still a million and of the 30 or $40
million who never get to live exactly
like they did before.
Take Africa,
Africa is it 30 percent are positive and
the continent would die out.
Remember that.
Guess what happened?
It was poor or 500 million Africans in
the eighties when it ended up the ads,
when they first detected in the guess
how many we have now,
like Africans,
I dunno,
1 billion still.
One third of them are HIV positive.
They almost tripled.
That is the largest population explosion
in the history.
The history of mankind,
despite each oem there of died away and
that's what they still see in the New
York Times on the journalists.
They don't want to hear about it that
you say they're doubling and tripling.
You see,
if you look for populations,
it's not the same article.
Occasionally they may get a little note,
so protease inhibitors do not
work or they they are a fake drug or
what do they do that's positive?
That's helping these people improve
their health conditions.
Anything.
Nothing name possibly.
It gets them into a new lifestyle.
I think.
You don't feel like having 10 days or
five dates when you're on protease
inhibitors.
Many of them show up and feel so it.
I Dunno how it balances off.
What about if you look at some of the
pictures now?
They con admitted in the Congo,
in the San Francisco Chronicle.
It was.
I have several references here.
Should get them out and show me they
they age very quickly.
They have liver disease,
they have heart disease,
kidney disease and the side effects or
what are toxic side effects is a
euphemism.
That's the only effective deaths.
HIV positive,
not no trucks.
Anything you want to do is fine,
but.
But the the.
We have to go back for a second.
The fact remains that in the eighties
and nineties I knew a lot of people,
a lot of gay men who were dying and I
watched them die very specifically.
They were dying with,
with,
with blue splotches.
They were dying because they couldn't
hold down food.
They were dying.
No,
very slow.
Ammonia ammonia a great deal in the
money.
I watched this W,
we all saw it,
and what happened was all of us said,
wait a minute,
this is something crazy is going on
here.
You could see it.
It was just droves of walking dead in in
New York.
It was such a tragic thing.
You don't see that anymore in the gay
community,
and all of them that I know are taking
these drugs that seem to be wonder drugs
because what they've done is kept people
alive and healthy and muscular and
vibrant.
You just don't.
In the gay community,
the AIDS HIV is no longer a death
sentence.
In fact,
HIV is,
isn't even something they talk about as
much.
And,
and so the fact remains that you don't
have an epidemic of death in the gay
community as you did in 85,
91,
92.
And until David who came along with
protease inhibitors.
So you,
something happened there.
Something had to have happened there.
I mean,
don't,
wouldn't you agree?
I mean,
you don't see people with Kaposi's
sarcoma.
Hospital wars are not full of people who
can't hold food down and dying in
ammonia,
uh,
who are HIV positive,
right?
So,
so how do we explain that?
It was at least according to the records
that I found in the light up yourself.
Mike callen for example,
you may know that,
sure,
that's my dad's name,
but it's a different Michael Gannon,
he says 1500 dates and with two or three
or four nights sometimes with nitride
inhalants and Philomena and cocaine and
all of these talks up when you can,
if you burn the candle on so many ends
that he was gone in five or 10 years
later.
That's what gets them sick.
Now,
at least many of them know,
at least suspect that nitrite inhalants,
the poppers causing cap,
Posey and wearing them out.
That is known
poppers.
So poppers are what caused Kaposi
Sarcoma.
Vague,
vague.
Many number of studies have directly
shown.
The coalition is a carcinogen.
It's a nighttime is in an isolating
ancient that goes through the blood and
causes the.
Essentially it's a skin blood cancer.
Brian,
where you're with your friends,
drug users?
No,
not all of them.
I mean the ones who know,
a lot of them were just theater guys.
In fact,
in fact a lot of them were theater guys
who were just gay.
I mean there are a lot of examples of
people who were not drug users.
I mean,
my God,
there are a lot of children that
database because they got it from their
parents or from blood transfusions.
They've new boil in the eighties,
there were all of them.
The kids have junkie mothers who had
lost intuit's in junkies maybe,
but the fact of the matter is they
weren't using drugs.
They,
they,
I guess the blood was passed onto them,
right?
Virus.
He ate the question of act now.
Act is what they gave them initially.
That was what they gave them when they
first started.
80 seven now act correctly,
me if I'm wrong,
was a cancer medication that was deemed
to be too dangerous.
Who?
They used it for chemotherapy and they
stopped using it because it was killing
people.
Like in the cancer.
They still use it somewhat.
Also for chemotherapy.
It's not different from any other
chemotherapy,
but it's a very,
very brutal one.
The old potent,
they're all brutal.
They're designed to be pulled.
They're designed to kill human cells.
Yeah,
because it's a retrovirus.
Retrovirus.
Human Cells,
human cells,
chemotherapy,
cancer cooks.
He signed to kill human cells and that's
what they give him.
They give him less and less so they tie
act on the idea though,
behind killing,
killing human cells,
especially in new cells.
The idea that because the cancer,
because these are retroviruses,
retrovirus is defined as something that
creates its own rna that copies the DNA
of the cell.
It's invading,
right?
So in other words,
it mimics.
It creates a clone of itself.
It's actually someone you any,
any,
any viruses do that,
but isn't that what a retroviruses.
Isn't that how you would define a there
to convert it to a Dni in back to one?
Exactly,
but that it creates almost a clone of
itself.
So when you create a medicine that kills
the virus,
you're also gonna.
You're also creating a medicine that's
going to kill the actual classes that
resemble computer viruses and computer
viruses in biological viruses.
At a certain point in time,
when you look at that,
the fact that it copies the host.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
That's an invasion of code.
It's amazing.
Viruses,
a terrifying,
terrifying,
but what we've learned a lot,
I'd seems from these different viruses
and how they react,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
I know you don't believe in protease
inhibitors,
but literature like I believe that your
work,
but I do deliver and they screw up your
metabolism.
They're not quite as toxic as act or the
DNA chain terminator,
but now
all of the treatments,
antiviral treatments or cocktails of DNA
chain,
terminator and protease inhibitors,
so you get many ways.
So Dr.
if somebody had HIV and guess what?
The people who take those eventually die
form and it's not so rare they die 10,
20 years later,
the doses so that they won't die
immediately.
I think that would be bad even for the
farmer,
but isn't.
Isn't that better than isn't dying 20
years later,
better than dying six months later as
HIV did that,
that would be better,
but it's not.
Was Not HIV.
There are millions with HIV,
you have nothing.
They exploding in Africa,
the population,
there are million Americans is still
around half million.
Still around no treatment.
That's the only way to go.
Most Americans that are HIV positive,
I believe or are getting treatment here.
I mean the ones that I know,
I know only three,
but I know they're getting that.
That's not a lot,
but I do know three.
Your HIV positive.
One is a woman in her sixties.
They will be in that.
Cool.
They will get.
Guess what they usually die from?
These guys are longterm treatment.
Toxicity.
Will it die from pneumonia,
from lung disease,
kidney disease and heart disease though,
and then they get dementia.
They get the chemo plane.
If you have these chain terminators
working your mitochondria,
you become more and more senile.
Very early.
It is described now in the San Francisco
Chronicle just a week ago.
They have this AIDS institute.
They're there for the first time.
Let it,
so maybe it's that talks to his.
Everything is.
There's no question.
There's no question that drugs caused
these drugs are caused.
That was.
That was ignoring half of these eight
patients,
so-called HIV AIDS patients or HIV
patients are dying from all of the.
We have a huge list of so called AIDS
defining diseases.
Twenty seven.
That's not enough.
With those talks you cause heart
disease,
lung disease,
pneumonia,
kidney disease.
That's what they die from.
Over half of a death certificate.
Now,
when did I.
These used to die.
They used to die from it very quickly
and I saw it by the droves.
Look,
the the theater community in New York
for example,
there is a disconnect.
There's something wrong if they were
dying by the droves and all the sudden
they got on these protease inhibitors
and the whole community became healthy.
So you're saying it was like a placebo
effect for the entire community or the
whole community changed its life?
Stage to life.
Is that what happened to the truck cues?
The recreational drug use went down
somewhat.
I don't know where it's now,
but it was word of mouth that this was
probably part of the department.
I mean,
Michael Calendar,
these guys guided themselves.
They say this lifestyle is untenable.
It's unquestionable.
I mean,
there's no question that it is a part of
the problem.
Everybody who does like hardcore drugs
like that,
it fucks your body.
Shadow it.
Hardcore drugs also create promiscuity.
When you're doing math,
you're fucking.
You're a guy without the guys doing
what's going on.
Nothing.
I'm just saying it's nothing new.
Three billion years old.
You can when you see.
Have you ever seen me have sex?
It's new.
It looks very original approach to
select interpretive dance because I
subscribed to on it and I applied there.
Their sex swings and drinks.
That chocolate shake.
He goes nutty.
Dude.
I had that.
Had that hemp proteins.
Awesome.
Oh my God.
That chocolate.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
That's really,
really good.
So,
so what happened to these people?
There's,
there's gotta be an explanation.
These people are sick.
They take the protease inhibitors,
the.
They're healthy,
they live.
But you're saying protease inhibitors
actually are toxic and very bad for the
body to change terminators,
right?
So how are they getting better?
They don't get better.
Where's the evidence that they get
better?
You don't get worse as much as they did
before.
It's fast.
Did it before.
I don't know it.
They acknowledged it.
They never cured anybody with these
folks.
Never any cure.
It's not cure.
It's exactly like diabetes.
You control,
you control the viral load.
And what they do is that it used to be
in the viral load would be huge.
And when you take the,
the,
uh,
the proteus neighbors,
et Cetera,
the cocktail,
it reduces the viral load to two levels
where your immune system does not have
to work to get rid of it.
It,
it.
Because what it does,
it creates a teflon sort of coding right
on the helper t cell and the virus
cannot latch on.
Now what happens according to what I
read in scientific American,
is the virus eventually starts to
disguise itself and the cell no longer
puts that teflon coating on and it can
finally latch on.
But I,
you know,
this is what I read.
You have a different,
what have you been in?
Your name is pine.
Yes.
So actor Brian,
not Dr.
No.
You'll record those tapes on the
establishment very well.
Yes.
But the reality is,
you said yourself 10,
15 minutes ago.
What you find in AIDS patients,
even those dying from it is not the only
antibody against it.
Dividable slowed is a new term in the
new invention of the establishment to
make it sound horrible.
What isn't probably what you can even be
found.
It cannot be found.
So what they use is they is the so
called preliminary chain reaction if you
heard about that.
Okay.
Molly's is the inventor of it lifts down
here.
Not far from the.
Also questions,
HIV,
AIDS lobby.
Nobody's there also.
Does acid
do just a little bit too?
Yes.
Okay.
Molly's is not your mainstream everage
scientists like to meet that dude.
He's a free.
You can get him up here.
Come up here is in Newport beach.
Dr.
How did you come up with,
how did you arrive at this conclusion?
Uh,
as,
as a molecular biologist,
somebody who deals with chemistry and
how it reacts in the body.
What was the,
what was the turning point for you?
You know,
you have all this science,
all these scientists saying one thing.
You came along and said another and
continue to say another,
you know,
what was it?
What was the,
what was the,
where was the Eureka moment for you?
Where as soon as I sell the papers from
Gallo published,
I knew that was,
that he was politics.
Well,
Gallo was painted as a really nefarious
character and a couple of things I've
seen,
but I mean the evidence was already in
debt.
All he felt was antibodies,
not virus.
Yeah.
For you guys have a gala was at decided,
is that nih?
Correct me if I'm wrong,
besides an ai to actually isolated what
you would call the aids virus.
The acquired immune immunity deficiency
virus as he named the.
Yeah,
a syndrome I guess.
Yeah.
So,
so anyway,
so that was.
Well,
it's not to be found.
He had a hell of a time finding it.
You may remember the scandal that he
didn't find it,
so he took credit for it when the French
actually isolated it.
So if you have violence with the high
note and killing people,
all you need is picking needle and you
have to.
This biosis can only hurt you if they
are biochemically active candidates.
Elton now there in large numbers when
they are latent,
neutralized by antibody,
no action,
nothing happens biochemically.
That was my starting point.
That is the situation after you
neutralize the virus,
if that were a cause of disease,
all of us vaccinated to polio would limp
it out and have.
Well no,
because polio is a dead virus.
No,
no.
They're all the same doll debt unless
the.
Until they get to a sale,
so that neutralized viruses.
We all have herpes.
We all have measles,
mumps.
We have often hepatitis.
Once it's over,
it's over.
Sometimes it comes back.
That's very rare.
That's why we all sitting around king.
Otherwise the microbes would have all
killed time ago.
Sure.
And here we see HIV.
It was a new virus.
We tried well,
but isn't the,
oh,
that's almost the argument with HIV,
what would happen was your,
because we're always exposed to
pathogens and different viral viral
viruses.
Your immune system is always working to
fight those things and does a very good
job of it.
You get the immunity immunity,
uh,
acquired a deficiency syndrome.
You get a virus that attacks directly
the immune system.
Now that's why you be young.
Men were getting very rare cancers that
only old men get from the Mediterranean.
Why young men were getting pneumonia.
Yeah,
why young men were getting pneumonia,
why young men were getting a meningitis
of the brain is weird.
Those young men who are getting it,
we're doing dozens of talks at once.
You can even delete the cdcs
self-reported gate,
let's scope analysis.
They deport dozens of talks and there is
not one in any of these statistics that
they published faithfully until 84.
When the vowels came.
Of course,
we changed overnight.
It was from Republican to Democrat or
calculate to Protestant.
No more mention it.
There wasn't one in any of these
statistics,
not even one who didn't do any thoughts.
They all went in and Michael Calvin and
all these guys who are into business or
law,
it's in all of course.
I'm the publisher of term then in New
York,
so when you're blaming then you're a
computing across maternity or you're
contributing.
I don't mind.
No,
but he doesn't want to offend dates.
You're attributing the mortality rate
that the.
The high mortality of,
of,
of death that for people who are HIV
positive to actually the amount of drugs
they do.
Yes and not the only and only six and
not the violence,
no sex advice column is acuity and
everything is.
How is it possible.
It wasn't possible to do.
I have so many dates because we didn't
have those trucks like in the Olympics
we played the records or into bicycling
with talks.
The same thing in the bedrooms to talks.
We know the way the route 5,200
years ago now you can buy them on the
straight Viagara when you can work with
phentermine and cocaine,
but icon all combined and you've got a
connection here.
Ornette,
none of this podcast.
That's the party that needed.
You're a doctor.
If I,
if I,
so if I have HIV,
but it really does make sense that gay
dudes with party that hard though,
if you think about the fact there's no
chicks down there was slow down to fond
and get knocked out,
but man,
it's just crazy bro.
Cocks and holes who just blow it off as
many times a day as you can and doing
whatever drugs you're friends have.
Well they did.
Do,
you know,
they did do a study on the average HIV
positive guy in the eighties and he did
have literally a hundred and 50
partners.
Like think about,
you know,
when you were a young man,
just one weekend in Vegas.
What it would do for your body.
Now imagine if you lived on Santa Monica
Boulevard and you were 36 and you would
just do a meth every night.
Cloud,
you know the like,
really,
please don't say plowed.
It would devastate your fucking t cell
size.
God,
I wish I was gay.
He says,
okay,
now.
Okay.
Here's the big question though.
Of course,
obviously.
How is it possible that every other
scientists,
not every other.
There's a few others that believe in
you.
A question.
The things that we might kary mullis for
independence and there's a few open.
Many of them cannot.
Is that what are the what the case is?
It's just an unbelievably controversial
opinion.
You can't say it.
Look at,
I have.
I have no more catches students.
I never get a count in 15,
20 years.
Since I questioned each job.
I had everything.
I had a lab full of graduate students.
I got every kind I was supplied.
Boy,
I got California scientists of the year
down here in Los Angeles and everything
it.
I was literally the blue white boy until
I question HIV.
All of these connections were going,
wow,
I'm,
I'm
so.
You are the example of someone who is
punished for thinking outside of the
box.
I'm vague,
but let me ask you,
have you.
Do you have.
Do you have peer reviewed research,
peer reviewed primary research to
support your theory because you're
dealing with a lot of research on the
other side and a lot of money was put
into it by a number of independent
organizations that looked at the data.
Okay.
Let's go to just show you this last
paper,
but anyway,
I have it in the back.
Kim?
Yes.
Oh,
because that.
Isn't that the big question for a
scientist?
What is your.
You want to go grab it,
grab it.
Don't grab it.
Sure.
Bring it over.
No big deal.
How many.
But I mean this was the last one and
this was the most difficult to get
published because it can't,
it can't be healthy.
Being a gay dude.
Just thinking about what it's like to be
a dude and think about no one there to
stop the fun and it just must be.
Can you imagine a day?
Your body must be just trying to like
find zinc,
you know,
and he goes,
I didn't get a 24 hour fitness right now
and I can see six gorgeous guys.
I could bang it out and not even look on
their face and let him it like that.
You said you can go to burke woman's a
bunch of girls there.
You can just bang.
I'd be like for free.
I'm married.
I can't do that.
So yes.
I mean initially I published in in the
best of the channels.
It was in science,
the first debate in the science,
which is the most popular American
children.
Yes,
and then I published in the proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences.
I was when I was still considered as
part of the club and then I became
execute excommunicate and then it
becomes very difficult.
Peer Peer Review means only the
establishment prevails.
That is censorship by the mainstream.
Lost everything in that is mainstream,
but it exclude everything that
challenges their own investments and
their own piece.
But that's a little unfair to scientists
who are really diligently working on
trying to find a cure for a lot of
diseases.
I mean there are a lot of,
as you know,
I'm sure and you know them.
There are a lot of.
There are a lot of scientists who are
independent thinkers who who want to
make a difference like yourself,
and it seems to me that more of those
voices would have,
would have made themselves heard in in
the,
I guess it's now 25 years that the aids
virus has been in,
in,
in the news.
Yeah,
so,
so if that's the case,
that's where I'm confused in the other,
the other disconnect,
the county's Taiwan.
Same letter to the Los Angeles Times
or something.
You get this new really concerned.
Can you publish the letter now?
He wanted to get a dialogue.
You will not get anything published.
Nothing.
It's complete censorship because they
don't believe because they believe the
science has already been settled.
Whereas in part by the there are several
journalist who interviewed me in the
past on this.
They did it once and not again even go
Jonah's channel and they hold one story
and then there were no longer invited to
conferences.
The quality center called the Centers
for disease control or have vouchers at
the Nih,
Nia ard into institute for Allergy
Infectious.
No more answers.
How many are excluded?
There are a lot of gay people.
I think though,
if they were sitting here would have a
very strong argument for you to say,
so listen,
I was dying.
I was 85 pounds.
I'm now 170 pounds after obviously his.
His answer would be when they're taking
the protease inhibitors are also weren't
doing meth.
That's his answer in part and one would
have to see those cases.
They're not so many happy faces on this,
on these trucks.
I don't know.
They're toxic.
There's.
I've read that there they have nasty
side effects.
They cause you to carry lumps.
Side effect.
That is the only effect you get.
You taking a post,
so how is it?
Here's the question,
side effects.
They didn't.
Most of them get it.
Now when they have a low t cell level,
they are asymptomatic.
They have no disease,
and then they start taking these clocks
and on average six years later,
they're dead on average.
That's the statistic.
Let us show you the guys like Magic
Johnson who is gaining weight all the
time and says,
I'm taking my medications.
When you ask or anybody asked what he
takes,
he never hear an answer.
My medications,
it's probably b vitamin C or whatever it
is,
but I don't know what it is.
So if somebody has HIV comes to you and
they said I have HIV,
am I going to die?
You say what up?
Don't take the first thing.
Don't take antibiotics.
That's eats by prescription.
That's exactly what you get from these
trucks.
What is what it is you.
You kill your t cells.
You caused cancer.
You'll kill your liver and your kidneys,
your heart,
your brain,
your.
Fortunately they become retarded when
they don't notice it anymore than the
smile in the camera.
We are fine.
So,
so here's the question.
How many people,
how many scientists working on how many
scientists are working on curing HIV?
Watch how many scientists are working in
the field on HIV and AIDS?
20,000,
$20,000.
How do they not understand what you're
saying and how do they not see what
you're saying?
How is it not being discovered all?
Let's stay with them.
How do they not understand what they are
saying for 20 years?
They're developing a vaccine.
Is the vaccine mater hard vaccine
though,
or is not the vaccine that we need?
It's.
It's vaccinating against something that
doesn't cause aids.
That's one answer,
but they don't live here that they
remember it.
Shannon is a British country doctor who
invented vaccination in 17.
90 three.
Not In 1973.
17,
93,
four 60 pounds that he got from
somewhere.
He developed the.
The pox vaccine is still called pocs
because is the cow.
It worked.
The extracted from the cow and
successfully protecting people against.
Oh,
now we have sog.
No,
long.
Long dead was Edward Jenner.
Okay.
Do you recall is still generic
vaccination in 17,
93.
I think he saw the milkmaids that they
weren't.
They were exposed to cowpox and I said
maybe if I.
and that's what I.
and here we have the scientists the
most.
It's the most advanced and most
sophisticated and by far the most
expensive scientific establishment that
has ever lived on this planet.
The American scientists to get 10 to
$20,000,000,000
a year to research it and they keep
saying,
oh,
we need a vaccine.
All we do is actively,
Edward Jenner did for 60 pounds in once.
He's 200 years ago.
Now they're missing out with a 25 years.
What do they have?
Ent.
So nothing they on a white coat,
but viruses are very different,
right?
We're not so small.
Parks being a.
do you have to,
as you said,
SARC and all.
We have against virtually all viruses,
we have vaccines and we have a perfect
one against HIV.
That's what the test measures.
There's antibody Novos.
Exactly.
We do because it works so well.
That's why Gallo,
the nation's leading aids researcher had
to steal it from France because he
couldn't get it out of people who have
the virus,
but they don't ask those questions.
That's what are the.
What are the.
What was the French discovery?
Because Gallo stole the franchise
franchise research and took credit for
it.
What were.
What were the French scientists say that
they were the ones who actually isolated
the HIV virus?
You would have never heard of him
without colonial US propaganda behind
it.
They said it could be every biology set.
Oh,
my virus could cause cancer or have
published me.
I'm famous and I get money and I'm
promising something horrible if you
don't follow me.
So that's what they all did.
The gala was one of the most successful
one.
He was just at the right time when the
AIDS epidemic came up.
I have device vaccines coming soon,
coming soon.
Here I am.
While his colleague in France got the
Nobel prize,
but he didn't because they call them.
So is that how it works?
Like he invents.
He starts working on some sort of a cure
and then funds role in.
It starts up a business of working to
develop a vaccine grants,
you know when you work,
how much,
how much money is involved in something
like that.
Just millions and millions.
It's an annual budget.
Over $10,000,000,000.
We have a team of people working a bit
over 10 billion for $8,000.
It's almost as much as because it gave
you.
What you're saying is it's an industry
and there's no way to stop this industry
with the truth that these are not
willing to look at the truth because
there's a massive amount of money that's
being spent perpetrating a lie.
That's what you're saying.
When did journalist or any scientists
really speaks up and sweat this year in
income DC?
Immediately.
Olga Kay,
molly's junkie,
crazy guy,
disbursed Nazi.
What have you mastered it so they have
immediately.
This is kind of pulling it out.
It did have an epidemic.
I mean,
we did have an AIDS epidemic.
I remember you saying that it coincides
with drug.
People are still.
You remember the crack epidemic,
man,
remember that very distinct thing that
happened when crack your whole.
We've had epidemics,
but the whole youth,
the large large scale use of
recreational drugs was known in America
after Vietnam.
Then he came back somewhat more open to
the rest of the world as before known
familiarized with drugs from Vietnam and
evolution by losing the war,
whatever it was,
and then all of a sudden tuck it.
Tuck epidemic picked up or the did
stated the yellow submarine.
Did it?
Everybody liked it,
but yeah,
that was.
That was the place for it.
It was coming in the seventies,
in the eighties,
and all of a sudden we have aids.
It's all talked related.
It.
What if it were a sexually transmitted
disease?
We have four and a half million
heterosexually produced babies in this
conduct to Duesberg.
If you can just try to talk into the
microphone.
Oh,
sorry.
There's tone.
There's.
There's lots of heterosexual sex.
What does the virus have?
I'll tell him.
I'll tell you there's an answer.
There's an answer.
Because in Africa it was a.
It was a heterosexual disease in the
United States and Europe.
Europe had never happened.
Now if there's a lecture about it and
see what,
they couldn't figure it out.
What was it was their secondary
infection was a poor healthcare.
Why in the world we're straight men in
Africa,
getting it by the drugs and the the,
the cases for straight men in the United
States are vanishing.
Unless you're talking about gay men and
intravenous drug use.
So what I'm saying,
here's what they found.
Colleagues,
executive trucks,
not with six and not with,
well,
here's what I read and maybe you can
help me with this.
What?
Juan Enriquez,
who was a venture capitalists who invest
in different kinds of medical technology
and deals with all this stuff.
He said,
what they found was there was a genetic.
There was a genetic variation in all
people of northern European extraction
who had survived the black plague.
That particular genetic variation makes
you very resistant to the HIV virus.
The only way a straight man gets HIV is
if it's pushed into his bloodstream with
a needle or through anal sex or
something like that,
or blood transfusion,
having regular vaginal sex with a woman,
and in fact even gay men who were having
doing the actual fucking doing the
actual sex as opposed to getting it were
the ones that survived the epidemic.
So there is no question that that,
that however,
in Africa,
in Subsaharan Africa,
they did not go through the bubonic
plagues that that we did in Europe.
They did not develop that variation in
their genes and that's why they.
That variation is missing in their
genetic structure.
That's why they get aids and that's why
the and that was the.
Any genetic explanation like that is a
taco suspicious.
Oh,
come ditching.
The genes are different between
homosexuals and heterosexuals.
That is not.
Yeah.
They would have.
If it's different genes are having
different sex.
Dr Duesberg I'm sorry to keep reminding
you of tuck cells.
Could you talk into the microphone?
We really want to hear you complaining.
So the any of the genetic argument says
it is very suspicious that in a
population to homosexuals would have
changed it.
A different sections.
We have a that that's not what he's
saying.
What he's saying is that there are
certain certain people that got it
through heterosexual means like they,
they,
they didn't have this genetic variation.
It doesn't mean that in America there is
no job and no way in the whole planet
even know heterosexual.
It's everyday deputy Dick didn't want
and scared everybody is going to split
into heterosexual.
All of a sudden even mainstream
conservative,
the public in whatever it is we're
interested in.
Even the John Wayne talk to regular
about it.
You have to do something.
Otherwise.
Our Kit's going to come on with eight.
Yes and nothing ever happened and is
sexy as or excuse as they used to be.
They produce.
They produce four to $5 million babies a
year and none of them get a no,
but the data wasn't.
Yeah,
all to the one I was saying,
one of the ICS.
The explanation for mainstream science
would be the reason gay men get aids is
because there's something called high
risk,
low risk behavior when you have
unprotected anal sex with another man.
You are.
Yeah.
You are those capital areas.
There are micro tears and the semen that
carries the virus can actually push it
into the bloodstream that that would be
why?
That would be like anal sex.
It's more,
but wait a minute from nowadays,
since you get porno movies,
you can get it on your laptop.
The girls,
maybe you can get your hands on your
lap.
Come on.
It's a serious discussion.
Is very serious,
but you see the girls getting into any
code.
That's true.
Some of them make a profession out of
it.
Some of these to pawn stars.
That's what I call my favorite poets,
and you're saying they don't get no
nowhere.
They'll put.
That's another prediction of the NIH
failed.
All the prostitutes will be the first
one you hear.
What did you hear?
The new laws that just got passed?
Measure b passed last I heard he saying
no more.
No more porn.
We're not going
to call her and is going to have to
start doing in Nevada.
One,
what they're doing is they're saying you
have to wear condoms.
Dental dams,
a dental dams to world men and women.
Men Dental dams during even worse is
that there's even something in there
that says that if you're a husband and
wife and you just want to broadcast sex
on a Webcam to our economy in your own
house,
you have to have a permit that costs
like 8,000.
Like a lot of money.
They did it.
Yep.
Did it.
The population did it.
It's not the government.
We voted that in.
That's shame on us.
They also voted that genetically
modified foods thing in it that get
voted in and I'm a fan of that person.
What is it that doesn't have to be
labeled?
Yeah.
I'm a fan of genetically modified foods
because.
Right,
but why are you a fan of them?
Not being late,
but yeah,
that's crazy.
How is it that is the domain to label
everything.
You should always be transparent and it
costs no more money.
It's a money thing.
It's a monsanto.
They,
they're,
they're buying it out.
Those sons of bitches.
So Dr Duesberg how many,
how many people like on a.
When you have these conversations and
you,
you talk about this connection.
How many people think you're crazy?
Yeah,
I,
I'm not so sure that so many.
A sure that I'm crazy.
They just don't want to.
Once,
just too hot a topic.
20.
Face it.
I see.
They don't see if you,
my colleagues,
my former friend Jay Levy or held or
found,
she was notified,
but Gallo,
we were close friends.
We met several times a year.
Conferences and trying foods and what
have you.
What?
Deep cannot talk about it with me.
They realize they have no good answers.
They have.
They would have known published it.
I would be finished.
I would not just be excommunicated
politically,
not get students.
They would pull from your home in,
in,
in lighting,
in a scientific paper.
That would be my the end of my song and
say,
look,
your dispute status,
or you can't answer it,
but they can't.
That's the topic.
That's why it goes on and on.
They have no answers why they can't make
a vaccine.
They have no answers.
Why the girls heterosexuals don't get
it.
They have no answers why they can't find
the bibles and you're dying from it.
That is a complete paradox in biology,
in chemistry,
in fact in science.
How can you get a fatal consequence
foreman nondetectable cause that is
absolutely electric,
isn't not cancer that serve my God.
You look at the second sale,
you'll see a lot.
That's what I'm doing now.
You have 60,
60,
70 chromosomes in there where there
should be 46 mm.
There is a big cost there.
You can see they make protein and on an
Ehr it's a difference.
You talk a little bit about cancer since
you work on it.
Well,
I want to stick to this so
they they see more than that.
Hardly any scientist wants to have a
name in a field.
Is naive.
Romantic as I was at and say,
okay,
we have to go the other way.
This doesn't end up.
They have made their career.
They have.
They put a professor,
they get their merit increases.
They consult companies or owned
companies and they have to tell the
postdocs and students in their company
so we on the wrong paths.
We have started all over that.
Hardly anybody is able to make that.
The wives would beat them up or the kids
would say,
where's the money?
They lose.
They would lose their jobs or their
investments.
They piss away the investments.
If this is true,
how is it that you're the only one who's
talking about this?
You're not the only one,
but I'm.
I'm as a friend,
good friend of mine,
a publisher from New York.
Have you been a scientist?
Also a hobby.
He was editor of nature biotechnology.
He wrote this book about me.
How do you unpack how to add butter,
your own pet here?
When we know,
I mean he meant it when he said this,
he explained it how it happened just for
being caught an ethical scientists to
say what the,
what the science tells me.
Have you debated any other scientists
about the subject of times in the
beginning,
even in the journal Science,
there is a debate between me and Carlo
Plattner and timid and it's called
equality policy form.
I,
my part was called HIV is not causing
aids.
There's,
it was.
And then he could answer to each other.
Ones that don't.
Then they hold one more editorial about
it and then they don't want to write
about it anymore.
So that's the only time you've ever sat
down with another scientist and had a
form.
Well,
no,
it's not the only table.
There were several other occasions here.
But what do they say to you?
What is their response and what's wrong
with their response?
So what is their response to your
arguments that it's all drug related and
then the,
these,
uh,
having a,
a,
something that we can only detect it in
the form of an antibody and saying that
that's what's killing you is ridiculous.
It doesn't work.
It is a Duisburg doesn't know indirect
mechanisms in individ causes and
cofactors.
And once I'm gone,
they don't mention the cofactors
anymore.
They named me factors like drugs.
What drugs,
lifestyle choice,
lack of sleep.
Dr.
There are a lot of doctors who are
medical doctors that you go to when you
have HIV and you take your drugs and
they're in the trenches.
They'd been there a long time and they
are,
they are involved in prescribing you a
certain amount of medication to keep
quote unquote your viral load to a
manageable level.
These are people in the trenches that
watched people die and are now keeping
people alive with those drugs.
So I'm just curious as to all those
doctors that are doing that in Africa,
in Europe and the United States in East
Asia,
etc.
W w,
w,
and I know there's a lot of money there,
but they are doing that work.
It seems to me that if it Wasn't
Working,
if they hadn't seen direct results,
and I'm talking about non drug users,
they hadn't seen direct results say in
africa With heterosexual men when they
were dying and now they are die.
It seems to me a lot of people would
say,
hey guys,
people are still dying at the same rate
or whatever it regardless of lIfestyle
change,
people stick to their lifestyle.
For the most part,
no.
In America is the minimal amount of
eight cases like 30,000,
40 $0 a year and guess who they are to
certain male homosexual sin asserta
junkies and that is because of a virus.
It's a small.
It's not by the toes.
As you say.
It's a very small population.
It's always the same list groups and
they get these talks,
so if you are a little scientist other
than the doctor prescribing pills and
doing what all other doctors do and
following what they call standard of
care.
If you violate and say,
I don't prescribe anything,
they come and so you sometimes you,
so anyway,
so they could skype,
but what you need to prove that these
trucks are doing things in animals or in
humans,
you need to do a controlled study,
totally controlled study.
You have to have,
let's say here and I identify with hiv
positive men,
gay or heterosexual,
whatever they are,
and they have another,
another hunted,
matched same age,
same lifestyle,
maybe soldiers with the us army.
You have to have two and they are not
treated and then we'll see who is doing
better.
Then you'll find out,
but when you use three talks and this
truck and that truck and that countertop
on top of them and don't comply and sold
them down the toilet,
all of these stories are very well
known.
You can only guess and they say,
okay,
my truck works.
It costs a thousand dollars a month.
Very good business.
It's lasting three or four or five years
until they're dead.
That's what the drug companies lovell
longer than that.
I mean,
people are on average about five years,
but they don't tell you that inhibitors,
untuck,
I know people are living now.
Your.
They always know somebody like magic
johnson.
He's gaining weight and I saw a lot of
people die in six months.
Seven months is in the eighties and
nineties night I've never seen that.
Even now they do,
but only when they faithfully take those
plugs,
but they often say they do and then they
don't have a microphone,
so it's a.
It is in order to prove what you're
saying and what they tell you,
all their trucks works.
They love to sell those stocks.
It's real good business and thousand
dollar month.
That's what for the rest of your life.
That's exactly what our companies love
best.
It's like chemotherapy.
it's also a thousand dollars a month
except it doesn't use the last that
long,
but what you need in order to pull if it
works and have a hell of a time within
cancer,
they've never done it done.
It was eight.
They did it once in 87 and the
consequences,
the results were very devastating to
people on set.
A 10,
20 percent of them were dying while
they're treating them and they only get
easy,
wasn't it?
Wasn't effective what it is.
They say that's what the admit now,
but for years they this audio,
you're a denialist you.
That's one of the words they use.
I remember when they see they was always
like,
you took it and you just hoped that it
kept you alive a little longer than they
give.
These companies are toy treatments,
blood transfusions.
Many of them because their bone marrow
was gone from act look really good.
then two years later they're gone.
Yup,
but it takes a while to develop,
but we're asking your doctor,
show me a tItle,
scientific study where you have treated
and untreated and show me that the
treated ones live longer,
even one day longer.
I would like to see why.
I think there's a lot of evidence to
that,
but I don't have days none.
There is no such study except the oil
you to act,
which you already pushed aside a little
bit because you heard it the first time
you do.
You have much improved,
easy,
tina.
What did act is still terminating dna
synthesis.
You use less now because you don't want
to die during the trial,
so you're.
But you're.
You're explaining it as if it's like a
conspiracy,
like they all are aware of it and
they're poisoning them less to keep them
around longer,
but they know they're selling the
poison.
Don't know whether they all totally
aware of it.
How is it someone has to be aware of it
consciously lower the dose to keep
people alive longer,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
How conscious do you hear it from all
sides?
You believe it.
You know,
I,
I think there were a lot of good
soldiers in sterling.
He could have said,
look,
let's stop this.
We go home.
So it takes awhile to change your mind.
They took 1945 and another 10 million.
What?
so you think that all these scientists
are aware of this issue,
that all these people who are working in
the hiv aids field or in denial or do
you think it
denied?
I don't like to use these words.
They're not that clear headed that they
will be in denial.
They have heard it so many times.
Each job so terrible.
Even act and tuck designed to kill human
cells.
It's a picnic compared to hiv to do with
you,
but then you ask them,
what about the 30 percent of africans
who are said to be hiv positive or 40 or
whatever high percentage.
Why on data?
Well,
it's a different strain comes to the
story that you had played for high
founded years ago and whatever this put
sheet of buying something or what have
you done.
They might tell you that they are dying
And now they're not because of the
drugs.
That's what they would tell you.
They don't have that many talks enough.
Not even.
Not even bill gates and burst webcam
could have pleaded so many people in
makeup and make him wait.
They have now from 450 to one point 2
billion.
That's pretty good for a wireless.
Hmm.
South africa's population is growing,
exploding going is actually putting it
very mildly from 450 to over.
The only other explanation is there
making super aids and they're going
bring it over here and it does.
It doesn't kill them.
A different strain.
They found it's the same test stop.
You're doing lies.
It's a super.
Aids is going to kill us,
but not them in the africans.
Is there a similarity to you between the
what your research with cancer and with
aids?
Yeah,
sure it is.
It came from the same starting point.
When I mentioned briefly when I first
came,
the hot thing intensity search was to
find cancer biosis and that's what it
came you trying to find the house and
the houses were the top of the basic.
Sure.
Cancer was a retrovirus.
I remember reading that got did two
miles was the most popular.
That's where I came in studying that
because it wasn't killing cells.
Unlike most viruses like polio and soap
and flew into measles,
mumps,
fifth kills assemblies.
These replIcates that,
they killed the cells and replicate in a
dying cells and then kill more,
but let's have a strategy.
They essentially move into it,
like you're engrossed would move into
you and they stay.
They stay part of the senate and
essentially tax it a little bit inside,
but very little there.
So mooches.
Yeah,
so muchin past luci cells,
they don't seriously did.
Don't do much.
They did.
Then they are neutralized by antibody.
You cannot even find it valuable when
you look hard enough.
Like with the methods we use no viral
load.
All this bullshit work expressions for
finding a needle in a haystack that they
don't do anything in any sales and
they're ubiquitous.
You find them in cows,
you find them in docs,
you find him and find him in whites.
You find in monkeys what kills you with,
uh,
with cancer and what cancer is a very
serious different business.
Then you have one sale,
one not thousands or millions infected
one that changes its chromosome.
That is possibly the solid of a casino.
Chinos,
some excellent.
And normally we have 46.
All of our sales,
46.
Then they behave when the pope comes,
work with and the controls work with
into building years of turning up of
life.
They've worked pretty well.
Now you change one out and make a new
species and it screws up all of these
controls.
It's a very different set attributable.
Presto call on or lung cancer has 60,
70,
80 chromosomes instead of 46.
All controlled health.
Or do you.
Do you believe in chemotherapy?
Yeah.
Yes.
About it there you'll have side effects.
That's a good word for side effects.
It detects cancer,
but for sure the cap tax you too because
there's no chemotherapy that can tell
the dna of species or from a cancer cell
that just came out of your own.
Distinguish,
cannot distinguish,
so the only edge you have and
chemotherapies that the cancer is
relentlessly coin and in adults,
many of your cells are not going or it's
just staying equilibrium.
You don't code anymore.
You don't work.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
My chairman of my accent.
Talk.
Gaining insights.
Replicate.
Yeah.
replicated.
so those.
That's what the chemotherapy works on,
on replicating sense and the little edge
we have is your heart.
Your brain,
your lungs,
even they don't call in adults.
they replace things here and then the
plot,
the skin,
the gods,
they call everyday like casey and that's
where you see the effects of
chemotherapy first to become immune
deficient.
They lose hail,
they lose weight as exactly as the guys
you describe when they take act in these
trucks,
they cannot keep their food anymore
because the intestines or school.
What is your.
What are your thoughts on the new age?
Ideas of what keeping the body alkaline
to avoid.
Cancers are bullshit.
I doubt it will work.
You know,
you don't believe in like iot is
antioxidants,
first of all.
That's good stuff.
No,
I mean,
but it doesn't work.
Me keeping the body alkaline.
That doesn't really follow all the rules
that my grandmother gave me come home
early and to sleep well and it's.
It could dive then you're doing all you
can do to what you do.
Eat meat and stuff and.
Yeah,
but I,
I eat less than I used to.
You don't need as much not pick.
I don't know why.
Maybe that's sort of terrifying as much.
Yeah.
Knowing as much as you know about
viruses or is it terrifying like being a
person,
like thinking about your body constantly
at war with all these different invading
armies that are trying to kill it.
That's what these viruses are
essentially,
but we have emerged out of a ocean of
microbes and viruses,
but syp at hip because we have an immune
system that is totally equipped to go to
war to to keep them down for 300 years,
80 years.
That shit starts falling apart.
Who dies from an infectious disease it's
in,
in this society is hardly anything.
The last serious infectious disease
epidemic was flu in 1988 at a time when
we didn't have vaccines yet.
We didn't know dna and rna and proteins.
Yet we didn't even know dietary
vaccines.
Vaccines have been the most amazing
invention that now after world war two
when there isn't any polio.
Polio had a little deep theory of
whooping cough,
pertussis and measles.
In fact,
one of the things that is always under
underlooked when you read history is
that most people you read about in
history,
including presidents,
kings,
peasants,
and ability all lost at least one child.
That was a huge part oF of the of the
character of our ancestors are very
recent ancestors.
They had all lost at least one child
child,
and if you have children,
you know how,
how epic and how tragic that would be
and how unthinkable it would be.
All,
all,
all.
most of our presidents are the people
that were the elite,
the most wealthiest of it touched
everyone.
It touches everyone and that's something
that we.
We are very lucky to not have to lIve
through.
For most of us,
we have answers.
We hAve answers for those pathogens,
answers for those viruses,
answers for those epidemics.
Biochemistry didn't have biochemistry.
They didn't know what he takes to
maintain an optimal immune system.
Even even if you eat so called junk
food.
Now in burger king,
get salad leaf there with some tomato
slice.
It may not be there,
but we didn't know it costs.
Garvey didn't know vitamin c deficiency
that queen victoria,
I had a lot of booths and schnapps in
eight,
seven except poor coast,
but it didn't have a banana or half a
year.
That's right.
So that post why the mortality and the
susceptibility to infectious diseases
was much higher.
The old days when you didn't have any
antibiotics of course,
and you didn't have any anesthesia.
Anesthesia made.
We've made great inroads and you give a
lot of credence as we've talked to you
give.
It's very interesting to hear you talk
because you're so mean.
You're very.
You give a great deal of credit to a lot
of mainstream science.
Where you deviate is in one area which
is this like a he listening to you speak
about the effective nature of a
chemotherapy on a virus on,
on,
on cancer for example.
Where you veer off is very specific and
that is in the question of does hiv
causes aids?
So I listened to you and you're so lucid
and you're so scientific is trying to
say you're crazy without being.
No,
no,
I'm not.
No,
What I'm saying is that what's what's,
what's interesting to me is that you're,
you clearly are a scientist who is
immersed himself in the traditional
notion of,
of,
of peer reviewed study,
of double blind study.
Changed the way you look at this
argument for not yet.
Not yet.
Probably not.
Because I'm not a scientist.
I don't have.
I have somebody on the other side here
sitting here.
I don't know anything.
I just read stuff.
I don't.
What do I know?
I don't even know what he's talking
about.
I just,
I can parent.
Well,
your articles are you.
Do you know?
I buy my own experience where I did with
my own eyes.
See young men die,
uh,
a lot by the droves.
I saw them die and
then I saw them get better.
But not many of those young men.
We didn't really get to this.
How many of those young men were not
doing drugs?
How many of them?
I don't know.
I don't know if you had a gas.
Any of them.
A lot of men that I knew who died who
were dancers and who we're targeting.
We're not necessarily drug addicts,
but they partied.
We partied a lot.
Yeah.
Having having said that,
having said that,
when even those drug addicts even.
I mean,
look,
the gay community still does a lot of
drugs.
They do a lot of math.
They do a lot.
They do a lot of stuff.
There's no question that you can ask
anybody,
but the fact of the matter is even with
that drug use,
if you go to the abbey,
if you go to these places on in west
hollywood,
they're not dying by the drugs the way
they were in the eighties and nineties.
That's where I have a disconnect.
That's where I have trouble buying your
theory because it's my own now.
You have to be careful by the way,
deducing from your own experience and I
know that because you're going to have
to start doing more gay research.
That's right.
By limited,
it's very limited.
Some leather pants,
but that strikes me is where you're
getting a lot of resistance because you
are.
You are clearly a mainstream scientists
and a lot of ways you just.
You just happened to have this,
this theory on it and it's interesting
to me.
It's actually,
it's very interesting to me that you are
just interesting.
I don't know enough.
Qc meet coldly,
collect the seesaw.
Me,
my arguments are completely conservative
arguments.
They say,
oh,
he's a deacon.
Crazy guy.
I'm presenting them with a hundred years
of science,
so our loads,
if you like I say,
show me one microbe or one virus that
causes a fatal disease.
When it's neutralized by antibody and
you see it making dna and rna and
potent.
That doesn't work.
you know there's no effect in biology or
in chemistry without the cost.
I'm sure this is going to be a very
controversial podcast.
We're going to get people far smarter
than us that are going to want.
I don't disagree with you.
Would you be willing to come back again
and have another scientist in here and
talk about it and have a little debate?
Good.
You dirty bitches in the scientific
community.
A challenge has been raised.
It's been raised,
man.
I,
I'm,
you know,
I'm going to ask her.
I can tell you that Joe Bryan was very
excited to come here because he was
like,
this guy can't be right and he gets
very,
you know,
very passionate about his ideas,
but he's befuddled right now.
You've got him befuddled.
I am the funnel and the funnel because
you're so,
you're,
so.
You give so much credit to mainstream
science.
You get so much credit to medicines that
actually,
uh,
I mean,
you're talking about viruses,
vaccines.
You're talking about chemotherapy both
secretly hoping you'd be more obviously
crazy.
That's right.
And by the way,
you're very likable.
I could wear the uniform where the
together that's,
that's even worse for your career.
Then the aids thing,
you just made the nazi salute.
He actually it to him.
He flipped off Peter Sellers.
I'm still going to stick to my guns and
I still do that and I'm still gonna say
that I believe that hiv causes aids.
You know what I believe?
I believe I'm too stupid to understand
this argument to unread too.
I'm going to go with the vast majority.
Joe.
You know what I just thought of when he
first got here,
we were talking about castles in
Germany.
I want to go to Germany and see the
castles and stuff like that,
and then I just noticed that the,
the,
the nazis holding a white castle tee
shirt.
You just work that in because we weren't
talking about castles in Germany.
I was talking to the doctor earlier or
try to work with it and planted it.
It's just.
So you mentioned the white castle.
That's his new thing.
Fuck,
how dare you.
Do you ever come to standup comedy?
Do you ever watch any standup?
Dr.
Vickery vanity,
but I love it.
There's not a lot of stand up to come
out of Germany.
They're fairly linear people.
They make good cars though.
Yeah,
make the shit out of some cars.
It will invite you to a shelter.
So some good headway in munich and in
paleo.
Wouldn't eat it on stage here.
You bring that bitch to the comedy store
watching meat hooks.
You ever hear christina leah here?
Here.
Chris is german guy where he talks about
how I've never seen kristalina do call
it,
talks about how scary like a german guy
threatens you.
It's like,
you know,
what are you to do,
bro?
You're going to have,
and I have already pushed until my
friend has this whole amazing thing,
right?
They just show up and I have already.
I would threaten you,
but I have already pushed into my
friend.
That guy's dies.
Yeah.
How did the germans get to be such a
calculating,
not wanting to say emotionless,
but controlled people have done happen.
The most disciplined people in the world
here are.
They know all of that.
If you look at that,
whoa,
yeah.
Lots of underneath it fucks up with the
more god that shit get away from the
theory goes.
That theory goes that the germans were
very,
very civilized people and a very
suppressive.
They're very oppressive,
oppressed,
and suppressed.
Manners,
protocol behavior.
A delineation of authority is very
important and and all that.
Keeping all of your animal in check was
what?
What?
When,
when chaos struck,
it just went.
They went crazy and light was so
possible to manipulate in that way.
That's why it's dangerous to control
people,
United States government and stop trying
to control people.
You're creating nazi Germany.
Germany was a great to the notion of a
totalitarian regime to totalitarian,
meaning control over it.
The total person,
not only in their body,
but their mind.
That was a.
That was a fascist nazi notion,
wasn't it?
That was an idea behind that,
and they're the ones who invented
crystal meth way.
Give that shit.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
they use
it on.
That's how the kamikaze is.
They talked him into slamming the
fucking planes and boats and shit.
They were left out of their head.
All these japanese.
I don't think so.
Oh yeah.
Look,
I don't disagree with you.
I've been wrong earlier.
I bet you're wrong now to excuse me,
sir.
I've never been wrong.
He shut you down,
dude.
about cancer
in the.
In there,
but it was in there.
Yeah.
Well that's really popular with
soldiers,
amphetamines and steroids too.
I mean,
look,
if you want them to have some people out
there killing for you,
you want them hopped up on pills and on
roids you do drugs
now.
I can't get them.
Shows you how things have changed.
In the seventies,
eighties,
when I was fairly popular and the
students were much,
much more open.
Students sit tight.
Tight disc.
That's the only cocaine.
Avocado.
The students.
Did you ever do acid?
Do you ever try out?
What about weed?
Who did that?
I tried a couple of data and didn't do
much good for me,
but a cocaine is like Texas.
A lot of fun.
Shit.
If it was lines,
not dejected,
but the way you just said that to it was
lines not injected.
Like who the fuck is injecting?
Who?
I want to know how hard.
so german it was lance.
We didn't inject you party hard.
Have enough.
Let's see.
I asked a student to get me some food.
I think too.
They would call a campus project.
Yes.
They would go on a tight budget.
Why not even got to speak with samsung
now?
Still teaching what?
What happened?
Limited.
No.
Captured student came to me or did they
told him this year,
then we'll wait for 15 years.
No cans.
It's.
I'm surprised that I'm still at a great
price for your point of view,
mike.
I mean I really sacrificed a lot of
status.
I was told you I was one of the blue
white boys in the days I was close to a
nova for finding out the structure of
the retrovirus,
the chines of retrovirus.
That was me pulling the switch.
Chines chines nucleic acid,
the size of it.
I realized that the potential.
Wow.
Yeah,
so I was very popular in a fountain
uncle gene in one of them and so that.
Why didn't you keep your mouth shut
about?
Yes.
He.
That's jesus.
That's crazy though.
I know it is.
I'm just being.
I'm just follow orders.
I said somehow you have that feeling.
We have done it before following orders
or just do what's politically correct,
but it was because you couldn't find the
hiv virus that we couldn't actually
isolated.
Is that what it was that caused you to
know?
It was very clear that under those
conditions,
that virus neutralizing antibody doing
whatever it's supposed to do,
10 years after infection,
what does that mean?
If I was turns to crank in 24 hours,
if you get infected by flu or herpes
syphilis or mums or anything at any
party,
well if nothing happens in a week,
every doctor will tell you you got away
even swiped through texts three to seven
days,
but here you're saying,
okay,
you had some wild party.
Ten yeArs later you have diarrhea.
It relates to fighting disease.
That's the idea.
The idea is a virus incubates for a long
period of time like syphilis,
syphilis does.
It shows stone.
They have a very low iq,
extremely low,
but does manifest itself as a source and
then it comes back to incubate and then
it attacks the brain and this white
comes pick why?
When they treated it with mercury,
it's iatrogenic doctor induced disease,
they give you mercury and the and the
standard of care was one km of mercury,
the equivalent of act around the turn of
the century,
a day for a year to kill your syphilis.
Yeah,
by that time your align niche,
you got lots of people were most sugars
crazy.
By the way,
the word german,
it's a german or if they were very close
for a long time until the hurricane did
very well.
I think they were together.
Yeah.
So anyway,
that's.
That's the tertIary syphilis.
It's gone.
You don't hear a word about it.
It will say a penicillin to.
It's pretty effective.
You all not penicillin.
Penicillin was.
Syphilis was around for millions of
years.
People didn't get tertiary syphilis
surface.
No venereal disease can really kill you
or else we wouldn't be around the 70.
Created super pussy though.
That's where things got out of hand.
No syphilis though.
History,
I mean I've read a lot of history.
So this was a big player in was
tuberculosis.
You weren't dying from it.
Yeah,
already did.
Well,
maybe when the doctor came in between
mercury and arsenic,
then sooner or later you are gone.
You never wear a condom.
So what are you saying?
They were sick and they went to the
doctor and the doctor gave him something
to killed them,
but because they were probably recovered
as you're saying,
you'll of course,
so syphilis is something that you
recovered from.
Of course.
I mean syphilis is millions of years
old.
Millions.
It's like a step sold.
It hurts a couple of weeks and then it's
your annual rejected,
your immune system rejecting.
What about.
What about chlamydia and gonorrhea?
Same thing.
Well,
I don't know so well about chlamydia.
Chlamydia for women can actually be
sterilizing or.
Yeah,
but it's not killing.
You know,
a lot of times your body fights off.
Sooner or later you find them all so
dirty trick that you get diseases from
sex.
That is the dirtiest when my kolbe
shoes,
everything they get,
but they have not been all that
successful.
We exploding.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
We keep,
we think loud.
The civil case,
a dirty trick.
Nature plays on you.
They will sit and wait in there.
Actually joke.
Japanese created math by the way.
Kamikaze.
Yeah,
you're right about that.
Joe.
Kamikaze used.
I still don't believe it there.
I said,
yeah,
well,
the,
uh,
yeah,
the germans in creative japanese created
the,
the talked the kamikazes into it,
but the germans used it,
right?
Yeah.
They were all working together.
The japanese,
uh,
in those days,
that whole fucking kamikaze king is one
of the nuttiest things that warfare has
ever seen.
Just dudes flying planes mapped out of
their mind into boats.
Ooh,
it's a,
it's hard for people to listen to this
and not think that it's almost
impossible to be true.
There could be some sort of a gigantic
scandal on this,
uh,
this larger level and it's all just
about pocketing money.
How,
by how many of the people that are
involved in it do you think are actually
aware that there's no real connection
between hiv and aids?
Is there a percentage of the people?
Dave wouldn't see this radically see
the,
you call up with this as a scientist
with biosil biologist you,
it's hard to deny your own field is
says,
it's like the old man's still.
It's not easy to,
to burn it out and to change it.
Very few scientists are,
uh,
on the record to question their own work
and particularly when it's such a big
investment.
They did the a d eight squeeze searches
still favored anyway.
They get all the money.
They want to get the investment papers.
They have companies.
They never had it so good.
Never they would be.
And as long as they can.
When you asked him,
oh,
I used to ask them,
they always say,
well,
I'm not an expert on what gay lifestyle
is.
I'm not an expert on epidemiology.
I don't know why this was so slow.
My field is just look at the potain or
look at this talk,
but very compartmentalized.
I noticed that that's an excuse of day
to day.
Could easily do it,
but they don't want to.
They don't want to look at the side.
They say,
well,
in my niche,
I'm good.
I'm accepted.
I'm guessing.
Are there social consequences to
questioning as a lifestyle shoe?
You wouldn't be better.
Believe it.
I.
Most of my friends,
Chile is one of them in san francisco.
Auto co-discovered,
gallo,
montane a tiny bit talks to me,
but they.
I'm not invited to meetings anymore.
I have not gotten any nih.
Not one in 20 years.
That's usually the test of the
experimental scientist.
I got every con I wanted for 20 years.
I came in 64 for 20 years.
I had every cut I got.
I got the best deal,
the head,
and it's called an outstanding science
scientists reward,
which was seven years unquestioned.
What I did was I used it for that.
I said,
since I'm supposed to do a whiskey work,
look at this was hiv.
That's something,
oh,
we won't get anywhere,
and I thought they would hug me and say,
so you have done if you only use it for
the way,
but it the opposite was the case.
Then I couldn't make me this paper here.
This is a rebirth of one that was
published before two years before.
Aids to me is it's so politically and
socially charged as opposed to any other
disease because of the fact that it's so
predominantly affects the gay community
gets part of it,
but not all.
It's all from the scientists.
They weren't they.
They were on the wrong track with
viruses and I was one of them.
We tried cancer.
That would have been the big thing.
If he had found boluses as costs of
cancer,
we couldn't vaccinate in the deep cancer
would have been possibly under control
or even eliminated.
That failed.
No,
he all these luminaries a bishop and
varmus and baltimore donnelly take few
blocks down here.
They had all nobel prizes for that
already or temin with all my dissipated
in science and they had no,
we would.
They say,
okay,
my bios is not so important as I would
like it to be.
I finally had some.
I didn't get clinical relevance with
cancer,
but now with eight I finally am
clinically.
We have vowels.
That's really bad and In reality that's
what they like.
They know the important and now he had
these 10,000
plus each aids researchers in these labs
working for 20,
25 years.
Will it have you ever heard?
Which is most definitely bio's see New
York times.
It also the deadly wells each.
Hold on,
let me put one more point and basically
they're working with it for 20 years.
They have no vaccine because they could
make one.
Yeah.
We talked about that early and not one
of ever came down with aids from the
state levels.
Neither of them will take.
No,
maybe none of they have earned my.
Put mass.
Produce It for biochemical studies to
make vaccine,
you'll have to mass produce virus and
then you take the proteins out and
vaccinate and for the test do you have
to make antibody against seat?
You need tons of files.
Not one,
not a technician or the collaborator of
these 10,000
researchers that daily work with it have
gotten violence from.
From the,
from the one they call.
Isn't that odd?
It's odd,
but that could just be attributed to
being very careful with a deadly virus.
Onesie outfits.
I mean extremely careful.
We have about thousand doctors,
doctors
per year getting hepatitis infections
from patients.
Do you think they're bringing their
patients know that you're leaving out
something that's important though?
You're leaving out something if they
don't get it from working in tons of
violence.
Remember that's very important that.
No,
that is very,
very.
That's very interesting actually,
but.
But,
but let me,
let me just say one thing that I think
we're leaving out a great deal of the
momentum for aids research and the
reason so much money is devoted to age
research was because there was such an
epidemic in the eighties,
nineties with gay men who were dying and
they were.
They literally,
I mean it,
it brought gay people out of the closet.
It,
it organized gay gay people to say,
listen,
we're dying.
Nobody cares about us unless we get into
the streets.
Unless we really created a strong lobby
for research for this disease.
We're not going to be here anymore.
And if you talk to a lot of people,
Michael Collins,
one of the people who spearheaded this,
they said,
we have nothing to lose.
We're dying.
He's actually addressed this already
though.
He said that this is because of illicit
drug use.
I mean,
he's bringing something that people were
not doing drugs or something.
That's actually a fact,
the massive amount of drugs that were
being used and he's correlating it to
the group of people that were using them
who got sick.
I'm saying a lot of people say that they
were.
Yeah,
that's what he's saying.
And they were.
So now we have a.
We have a problem.
So who's right?
Not everybody in the streets in the
eighties,
nineties who were,
who were fighting and organizing and
putting all their time into this.
We're doing drugs.
Who are here?
No.
Okay.
But he's saying,
and he's saying even today,
that the people that are testing
positive for drugs,
they are junkies and drug testing,
positive for hiv.
Are junkies and drug users primarily
deal in America?
What'd you say?
Children are.
Unless you're a child,
unless you're a child from his mother to
a black children can get a feel.
He actually got into a blood sugar
transact.
What about hemophilia to get it through
blood transfusions,
hemophilia.
Where are the eight cases among
hemophilia?
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm just saying is that ever happened
where the head read ahead of fuel and
particularly it went up tenfold after
they gave him act and they got eight.
Well that makes sense.
The lifespan was increasing until 87 and
then he talked.
So you're saying that in showing that
they had the rush,
the antibody,
that the body was successfully fighting
off of it though,
but even though they show this antibody,
that was an excuse to introduce act into
the system to combat this thing.
It was creating this antibody body die
and then the body dies,
but a lot of people were getting a lot
of hemophiliacs.
People were getting weird diseases,
which is why they got tested in the
first place.
It wasn't like people were getting
tested because of blood
transfusions all the time,
but,
but there are a lot of people that were
that I knew that all of a sudden we're
getting.
My buddy,
he got a.
He got a huge blue thing.
He was rollerblading and he was this big
strapping guy who didn't do drugs.
He just had gay sex.
He did not do drugs.
He was a personal trainer and he,
my buddy will stand there and he had a.
He got a huge blue thing and all of a
sudden I went,
that's okay.
That's good.
What about guys that don't do drugs
and got aids?
What would happen with his.
Like his story.
We are.
That's
well,
he's telling you about one.
What I.
My buddy died.
Get maybe some.
There may be something to get on
medication than die.
No,
no,
no.
You could guide before medication and he
died slowly and he died without any.
There was no azt.
No nothing.
He fridays he didn't work.
Then the second he tries to act and then
he died.
Still sort of like makes his case will
act is known to kill people.
I mean they stopped using it for a
reason to act is a terrible drug damage
alive today if he had protease
inhibitors because.
Because,
because a lot of the people that I saw
who were dying,
who stuck it out and not take act.
Maybe you're right.
Aids was killing people who didn't look.
Listen man.
I'm sorry.
I watched too many people die with my
own eyes.
You can tell me you keep saying that,
but let me.
That act is what caused people to die.
Saying that what I'm saying,
what do you.
Are you.
Are you completely confident in saying
that you understand that person's
lifestyle 100 percent and you know they
weren't doing something that you
might've known about completely about.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
Most people will tell you who lived
through this in and doctors who are
involved in this will say what got these
guys sick was obviously something they
caught through either gay sex through
intravenous drug use and by the way they
died in a very similar way of things
like wasting disease and pneumonia,
karposi sarcoma,
terrible sores,
all that stuff.
They were dying that way.
Right,
but you see the issue in that like when
if someone goes and they find you when
you're sick and then they start treating
you when you're sick.
The the.
The issue with that is how many people
are hiv positive or tests for the
antibody but have nothing wrong with
them and then do no drugs.
Take no,
no medication and live healthy lives and
then eventually get tested again and
don't show the antibody.
They don't show their body's fighting
enough.
How.
How often does that happen?
It does happen.
there were a couple,
for example,
there were 50 cases per year in us long
before hiv came and it went up to
thousands of in the act days and so in
the.
In the case when the poppers,
poppers meaning email,
nitrates or nitrites and nitrates and
that apparently is unbelievably
devastating to the immune system.
It's media genic
jenny.
Yeah,
and I think.
Can I.
Can I just be clear on what you're
saying?
Actually you might also be saying that
if you get the hiv virus,
which you can catch now,
you have it in your system.
If you're also doing things that are
weakening your immune system like
poppers and things that's going to.
That's going to compromise your immune
system to the point where you're going
to get all these were where I suppose
the hiv virus is going to create a
situation where you're going to.
It will further erode your immune system
and you'll get these other diseases that
you might
daddy's.
Again,
something that would be verY testable,
but see the cdc a not a straight or not
own little.
They never report pneumonias or kaposi
sarcoma of hiv feep people as pneumonia
psychosis.
They can't do.
You have an eight statistic when you're
hiv positive,
then they report these diseases in the
tdc,
in engagement or in junkies that are not
antibody positive,
are not even in the same journal.
A lot of people never hear about it gets
lumped into the aids deaths.
That's what they do.
That's a political decision.
Of course,
it take hold diseases and politically.
how can you have a common cause for
dementia?
Weight loss,
fever,
pneumonia,
kaposi sarcoma,
dIarrhea,
leukemia,
and whatever.
Wasting disease.
It's 27 altogether from one cost for
anything in the first place.
Lumping them all altogether is nothing
but a money grab.
Did it's a mistake?
well,
I mean money.
It's much more ego tHan money In
scientists.
Really?
Oh yeah.
I didn't want to be famous and they want
to be in the history books and the
textbooks.
They discoVered something.
Gallo would sell his mother for a nobel
prize,
but a lot of people died.
A lot of people died of aids.
A lot of people died.
Act only came about after people were
dying,
but the people that were dying were
doing drugs.
That's what he's saying and I don't know
if you're right.
I wish I knew.
I wish I knew what you know.
How many people out there didn't do any
drugs?
Lived a normal healthy lifestyle.
Word gay had sex with the wrong dude.
Boom.
Died of aids.
That's what we had always heard.
That was the story behind aids was never
the drug use until I read spin magazines
article in [inaudible] 93.
I had never even heard it brought up.
When I read that article about when you
were talking about,
I was like,
this is crazy.
Because I had just taken my first hiv
test.
I already got a health insurance and I'd
take my first hiv test and I was fucking
shitting me.
I took a lot of our.
God,
I was terrified.
I thought it was going to die of aids,
you know,
I wasn't.
Dare you sir.
That's why I.
Dave porn stars.
It's never done any.
Yeah,
I've never done any.
Yeah you do.
But they do talk about hiring high risk,
low risk behavior and you can get the.
You can get the hiv virus from Ohio.
What?
Quote unquote high risk behavior,
right?
Versus low risk behavior.
How do
you catch the aids virus?
It's very difficult,
but how would you catch it saying it
doesn't exist.
No.
Aids virus.
So how do you say?
How do you catch something?
He kept saying you don't.
You don't believe there is something
called the hiv virus.
You said the aids virus does exist?
Yeah,
but not the aids virus virus.
There's no what you just said.
No,
I'm sorry.
Hiv causes your immune system.
You did not hear him say you said aids
virus.
What I meant is hiv,
which is,
which can be construed as the aids virus
because hey,
it's just me and acquired immune
deficiency syndrome.
In other words,
when you can be hiv positive,
you don't have full blown aids until
you're,
you've got all kinds of stuff going on
with obviously,
but so,
so the,
the hiv virus,
how do,
since we can test for the antibodies,
and by the way,
a lot of people who test for the
antibodies are what we were talking
about intravenous drug users,
gay men,
uh,
and then of course in africa to
heterosexual disease.
Why?
How,
how does that happen?
How did they get that virus in the.
Why don't most straight?
There's little known about it,
but I mean the best way to transmitted
is actually transfusions.
It's very difficult.
It is,
it takes on average from the literature.
Hemophiliacs for example,
coupled within without on the average
thousand unprotected contacts to convert
positive to a negative thousand.
Wow.
That cannot be a normal way of
keisha.
I had to say this is a very eyeopening
discussion.
Yeah.
I mean,
I have to say that you,
you know,
one thing for 25 years as we have and
then you come along,
you're,
you're raising questions that are,
that are very,
that are very interested too stupid to
answer those questions.
So this is the problem we're going to
have to.
No,
no,
no.
I wouldn't say just uninformed to
recognize that the fact that this is
such a touchy subject,
we're going to have to try to find some
scientists willing to do this,
but meanwhile we have to make sure we
don't get trolled and some crazy desk
squad fan his way in as a fake scientist
guy.
Yeah.
We're going to have to probably reach
people up and you can.
Yeah,
we're probably going to have to try to
reach out and contact someone and figure
out what,
what the hell.
I don't think that's the same.
What about dr drew?
I.
Well I tried dr.
Drew,
man.
I brought this up to dr drew about eight
years ago.
I've been following your work for a long
time and I brought it up to dr drew a
long time ago and like the last time I
was on loveline,
I don't even know how long ago that was,
but he dismissed it immediately without
even considering it and then looked at
your,
your website for about five minutes and
said something was wrong there.
And then,
uh,
you know,
but I suspect he might be full of shit
becaUSe he's full of shit about
marijuana.
He's always talking about marijuana
being unbelievably addictive,
addictive syndromes.
We find it to connect to the marijuana.
That's just not true.
The people that show anY addiction to
marijuana either they're unusual cases,
extremely unusual or it's a
psychological addiction much like
gambling or masturbating or anything.
So for him to,
as a doctor to spout that,
you know,
most doctors study,
they're very orthodox.
The medical staff,
by the way.
I like dr drew.
He's a great guy.
Don't get me wrong.
I just think the,
you know,
people get an idea in their head and
they rock with it.
And his idea is that sobriety is the
only way to go,
but as,
as a,
as a doctor and as a surgeon,
when you start talking about nutrition
to your colleagues and they don't know
what the fuck they're talking about,
it's taboo.
It's a orthodoxy is of,
correct me if I'm wrong,
is forced on you in the medical
establishment.
Well,
not only that,
the amount of nutrition information that
they're given during medical school is
so minimal and constantly changing.
Yeah,
no,
there's constant studies that are going
on.
I remember,
you know when,
when people have a certain amount of
knowledge in their field and they don't
keep up and the time goes by 10,
20 years,
like you might as well be the average
person on the street like you,
you know,
shit from 20 years ago things have
changed radically the way it is.
If you look at the ufc in [inaudible] 93
and look at what people knew then and
they look at what people know today,
day out now it's like,
well,
I love watching it just because it's so
nostalgic,
but it's.
It's an unbelievable example of how
things have gotten super,
super complicated.
super,
super quickly.
duck duesberg.
Did you know that Colorado and
Washington state made marijuana legal?
That's about time.
Isn't it beautiful?
Yeah.
They stepped up yesterday.
Oregon fucked up Though.
Oregon.
So sad for you.
Portland.
How dare you?
I dare you let that happen because
Oregon is filled with a lot of white
gangsters out.
Chill son and type dudes out there.
Oh boy.
So they never like.
They're not down with these fucking
hippies work.
Go to work.
Hippie.
I'm just kidding.
But Oregon didn't pass it,
but Colorado did is legal I guess.
Huh?
Medical marijuana passed in
Massachusetts.
Well,
what is the federal government going to
do?
They can it exactly.
Well,
they're not going to shut down the
medical marijuana programs.
The dea might occasionally bus people,
encourage people to not do it.
Threatened landlords and stuff like
that.
but it's really just essentially to keep
their business open with the da has been
been down to doing is they re these
medical marijuana dispensary,
they take all their weed,
they take all their cash,
they say they're going to process the
information and then they never do
anything.
So they basically just go in and crank
everybody the gangsta cash they go in
with strapped with machine guns and ddh
agathy step on people's necks.
I mean it's fucked up.
It's a jacking.
They go in there,
they take all the weedy tickle them and
they can by federal law they can't
prosecute,
but yet they just sort of hold that case
up and they don't do anything about it.
And occasionally people get prosecuted
when they find out that they're doing
something like this is a lot of dudes
who got into the weed business that used
to be in the illegal business,
you know?
And so they're doing shit shady and guys
get busted,
you know,
selling mass quantity taxes on it.
But with the real problem is you got a
bunch of guys in the dea that would
probably like to go bust scumbags and
probably like to actually make a dent in
their community and they're in a
situation where something is law and
here's the law.
The law is they're doing something.
They have to go do it.
They have to do something.
It's like until you change the law,
you have law enforcement officers.
They're going to be wanting to enforce
the law period.
It's a simple written thing.
It's written down.
Most laws are stupid as fuck.
But the we agree on them on them.
And that's their job comes prostitution.
Sure they do.
They hate,
they hate having to give people speeding
tickets to sit there with a laser gun.
That's not what they signed up to be a
cop for.
But it's part of the job.
But we have to do is make it so that
it's not part of the fucking job and
give them,
you know,
it's like the difference between going
to a medical marijuana dispensary and
stepping on some kid's neck who's a
college student who just got in because
he was high and took the job and going
to a meth lab is a very different
experience.
You know,
you,
you drive out into the middle of fucking
palmdale and you see a warehouse with
smoke coming out of it and you all storm
the building from email.
You might go into a bomb man.
You might go into,
somebody might drop some biker gangs,
hopefully machine guns out of their head
making shitty decisions being up for a
week.
Yeah,
it's dangerous as fuck.
Whereas they can go to a medical
marijuana dispensary and just walk in
and,
you know,
go take everybody's money and take your
business and scare the shit out of them.
It's not the da's fault,
the dea or a bunch of guys that are
fucking dea agents,
which if you're going to have like a
regular society,
you got to recognize what's dangerous.
And the regular site,
but a healthy society,
you've got to realize what's actually
dangerous and what's not.
I'm not saying things should be illegal.
I'm not saying you should go to jail for
doing anything,
but I'm saying there should be certain
consequences for knowingly and willfully
pushing addictive and dangerous drugs on
people like math.
There should be a social consequence for
it and that's where something like the
dea should come into play to restrict
shit like that district.
When you get that shit into communities,
it poisons people.
It infects just like a disease.
There should be massive amounts of
resources spent trying to stop that from
happening.
I don't know exactly how you should do
it,
but having a dea is not a bad thing.
Having an agency,
just like we were talking about,
the fish and game,
they regulate the wildlife and they do a
great job.
There could be a way of regulating the
effect of dangerous substances on the
american population because right now
they're dealing with this whole bath
salt issue man,
which is a real problem because they're
just taking a drug.
You got to go to the bathroom,
sir.
You wanted to work,
going to get an article.
The bath salts thing is they're taking
drugs and they just change one molecule
and they can say not for human
consumption and sell it over the
counter.
Everywhere you're.
There's an outlet that's not illegal.
They can't.
They can't even do anything about that.
So they have to pass drugs for those and
then they just keep changing what the
drug is instead of calling it bath
salts,
fucking garage sand call called whatever
the fuck you want.
As long as You say it's not for human
consumption,
you know,
lawn fertilizer,
decoration,
make some shit up.
You could sell it all day long and
people figure out that it's there for
you to smoke and get high and it's just
like a meth with something changed on
share.
So having a dea is not a bad idea.
Having drugs like marijuana to be
illegal is the bad idea.
It's a bad idea.
yeah.
Fucking government is.
The problem is there's too many people
and trying to manage 300 million people.
Ridiculous and trying to manage it by
having government nanny groups that
stopped you from doing a bunch of shit.
That doesn't hurt anybody.
Well now you're just going to ruin the
listening to you about anything because
I don't want to listen to you about
that.
You know,
the marijuana argument is one of the
main reasons why people have a distrust
of cops.
It's not about crime stopping or
anything else.
It's like the idea that I could be doing
something that I love doing and I got to
look out for cops because if I get
busted doing something I love doing.
That hurts nolan.
I might wind up spending the night in a
cage somewhere with a bunch of criminals
can get you can get fall down drunk at a
bar and,
and,
and that somehow.
Exactly.
You can throw up into a garbage barrel
like many of us have done,
you know,
just a bunch of wind literally poisoned
by and people.
People applaud it.
Dude,
I got so fucked up.
I threw up in the curb.
You,
it's so bad for you.
It's so stupid and it's everywhere and
nobody's complaining and there's all
these stupid people working so hard keep
marijuana illegal,
but we need to do is find jobs for those
fucking people.
That's what we need to do.
We need to have a compassIonate way of
looking at drug legalization and one of
the ways is looking at the people that
are making a living from drug
illegalizing drugs being illegal and go
after those people with positivity and
figure out a way to where they can make
a better living to transfer the people
in the dea that are responsible for
going after marijuana and find fucking
better use for them.
Actually put them in in some sort of a
positive function in the community
instead of being monetary vampires.
That's what they're doing there.
They're jumping in and stealing money
and then suck it into their system and
nobody can ever get it back and there's
no case and nothing ever happens.
It's not sense.
That's just like a gang stealing your
stash.
That's all that is and that it does
affect a government's credibility.
Of course it does.
It does when it's marijuana,
because you can't act like it's 1950
anymore.
It's 2012.
Everybody can get on their phone and
they can google something and five
minutes and read all the bullet in my,
you know,
they might called schizophrenia in the
who,
who's taken it and go and schizophrenia.
It might be a schizophrenia.
I also smoked weed.
You know what you're doing and you're
giVing 10 people fake weed and 10 people
real weed.
What are you talking about?
Even with all the pressure to make
marijuana,
you know,
to make it a dangerous substance.
They still can't find shit,
but yet it's illegal there.
This is an embarrassment as a human
race.
I think that the elections are showing
that,
right?
It's too fucking states out of 50 and
one had failed.
It was on the ballot.
Momentum is moving forward in that
direction.
It is.
It has to be hard to justify.
Like I always say,
I'm not even a big weed smoker.
It's just hard to justify how you make
alcoholic alcohol illegal.
I'm a big way.
I like the way.
That's the problem also is that people
getting uneducated views on weed.
People think potheads lazy.
It was because there's two different
kinds of effects.
There's the endeca effect,
which is just like sleepy couchy affair
because I don't like that.
I go with the sativa.
Look,
if it was only in the weed,
I would still smoke it every now and
then when you wanted to chill,
have a nice meal hanging out with my
lady,
my lady I said,
or like a black man.
No irony whatsoever.
Hang on lady.
My special lady.
You know what I'm saying,
but I much prefer sativa.
Sativa is what you have before you have
an interesting conversation or I have
energy on that stuff.
It's a different effect and it's not a
lazy effect and the reason why people
don't know is because we're in a
terrible situation where we have a bunch
of uneducated or uninformed people that
are dictating policy.
They're looking at things in the wrong
way.
These things are tools.
All these things are tools are there to
help us.
We deserve help us.
They finally figured that out in two
states,
Colorado,
which has always been ahead of the curve
and Washington state,
which is seattle,
was.
I did the more theater this weekend.
I seriously think about where we're
going to move for at least part of the
year.
Colorado man and wife.
The wife has family from there.
I used to live.
I'll move back to Colorado in a
heartbeat when the shit hits the fan.
Redbands.
ready?
You're ready to move to Colorado.
He's ready.
Dr duesberg,
would you be our scientific advisory in
Colorado?
Post post apocalypse because when the
scientist on,
we'll go get some cocaine and smoke some
weed burger,
be in his underwear,
fucking shooting guns off the roof.
Crazy german.
My.
Hey,
listen,
doses gluten.
There's.
It's very unfortunate that your story
is,
is a fascinating one and you know brian
and I have really struggled with this.
We've had this conversation without you
here many times and neither one of us
really qualified to have it.
So to to have you here and to talk about
this crazy subject.
I'm sure there's going to be a lot of
people that are responding to this in a
bunch of very different ways.
Yeah.
There's people listening now.
No,
we don't want them to call.
They would get crazy and just yell out
or have gardened,
butthole and hangups when.
Well,
there's for sure a lot of twitter people
will react on twitter.
Are you on twitter?
I'll sometimes look at it.
You do you have an account?
What is it?
I don't even know.
I don't.
Oh,
you just read people's.
What's we need to start you at twitter
account.
Were you done with that?
Fine.
Brian.
See if he could find them on twitter.
Name.
There you go.
What,
what,
what's your uh,
website duesberg do you e s,
b e r g.org,
right?
Correct.
Com.com.
Dot com.
Did you used to be.org?
This one org for the academy?
Yeah.
And um,
if people want to read more about this,
is that the best resource resource to
speak on?
Duesberg duisburg on aids.
The book websIte.
Oh,
it's a website.
Duesberg on aids.com.
Is there a book that you've written
about it and I wanted to bring you a
copy.
She's inventing the aids virus and is
that available on amazon?
All that for me.
I signed it for you.
You know,
you're a very brave man.
Uh,
I don't know if you're right.
I said,
it sounds like you are,
but I'm too stupid.
And if we had a guy here was equally
bright,
who opposed you,
I would be baffled and stuck in the
middle.
We'd both be like,
well,
I don't,
you know,
it's,
uh,
but it's what you've done in this belief
and that you're right,
is a very,
a very brave thing and it's,
it's an interesting story and it's,
I've never really quite understood the
whole academic process and what's
involved and only like,
you know,
looked at it from the outside.
So to,
uh,
to hear you describing what it's been
like trying to,
trying to make an argument for this and
being treated in what seems to be an
unscientific way.
It seems to be a biased and,
and,
and really,
uh,
in a way that's actually damaging to the
distribution of information because you,
there should be,
if you are a respected scientist,
which you are,
there should be some concerted effort to
prove you wrong.
There should be some,
like,
it seems like you've made enough waves
with your book.
You're,
you're in a prestigious enough position
at the university of California,
berkeley,
that you should be considered and at
least refuted by the people that
continue.
Instead of doing that,
they've decided to ignore you.
Yeah.
Judy's underhanded things like
underhanded tongues,
like a misconduct investigation,
which is pretty heavy.
So when did they do that?
It was a one and a half years ago until
they hear about the cocaine.
You're doing coke with students that I
think that's a podcast well,
st in to sink your ship.
If the statue of limitation expired.
Yeah,
those were hippies.
Man.
You've got old days back when it wasn't
even illegal.
Boy,
was there a time.
Do you remember the time when cocaine
wasn't illegal?
Remember that?
When was that?
Was that the seventies now?
I was,
it was illegal.
It was,
it,
it was before,
I think in the forties or thirties.
Twenties in the first part of the last
century.
It was legal.
Yeah,
because you took a coke coca cola.
In fact he took a.
You get a buzz off coke.
Yeah.
That was the old days.
Cocaine in coding,
whIch is a date assuming that by your
meat can cuff,
was made illegal in 19.
Oh seven.
Damn.
They figured out.
Coke is bad for you in 19.
oh seven.
You take it once and you're like,
oh,
this can't be good in the world is you
don't do anything.
You just sit in her room.
Yeah.
The us government.
Uh,
the
first effort from the us government to
control cocaine was the inclusion of the
pure food and drug act effective January
1st 19.
Oh,
seven.
Which required the labeling of products
to disclose the contents,
including alcohol,
morphine,
opium,
cocaine,
heroin,
alpha or beta.
So what it essentially is saying that,
oh,
cannabis,
much different things,
but there was no labeling back then.
So that was the first effort.
So it wasn't necessarily that they are
making it illegal,
but they let you know.
So the comprehensive drug abuse
prevention and control act passed.
And in 1970,
that's when a cocaine saturday only.
Yeah,
they regulated and taxed opiate and
heroin in 1915.
But it wasn't until 1970.
So what's You're saying is true that the
after the post Vietnam war,
those people from that era fourth,
that's when the real drug problem
started in America.
And in nineTeen 70,
that's when,
that's when they cracked down on all the
psychedelics.
That's when you know mushrooms and acid
and everything else became law,
which is incredible.
Can you think that all those years
before that,
even though marijuana has been illegal
since the thirties asset and mushrooms
and all that shit,
they were illegal until 19 crazy.
No other music was so good,
man.
No wonder,
no wonder the beatles were as lonely
dude.
They were in tune.
You can't make the doors with the white
album.
Crazy album man door songs like,
father,
i'M going to kill you.
You,
you're not going to make that.
And I'll say it also ensures you die.
At 27,
every one of them.
Oh yeah,
they fucked hendrix.
Joplin,
jim morrison.
Certainly not good for you,
but neither is aids.
They died of aids essentially.
If today they'd be thrown away.
Wait a minute.
It's ready man.
I have got to a jail.
Fuck.
Listen,
this podcast is overlays gentleman,
dr duesberg.
Thank you very much sir.
It's been a pleasure having you on.
Fascinating and enlightening and uh,
you,
you opened a lot of people's eyes and,
and confuse the shit out of a lot of
others.
So I'm sure we're going to.
I'm hoping that we're going to get some
response from a legitimate scientist is
willing to sit down next to a zombie
puppet and a mannequin victims and we'll
try to put this together and,
uh,
and bring you back and hopefully we can
shed some light on this.
This is very,
very,
very fascinating.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
My friend Brian Callahan won't talk to
you about aids.
He will only say funny shit.
Thanks.
I'll be in helium.
Yeah.
Helium in philly and brian and crew,
including tom skirt and tony hinchcliffe
wilkinson.
And doug benson.
That's right,
and you'll be the dates
dayton tomorrow,
cincinnati,
friday,
columbus,
Ohio,
saturday.
All the tickets are@deathsquad.tv.
Use the coupon code red cross and savers
get two for one tickets and also 10
percent of the proceeds go to hurricane
relief in Wisconsin.
What more do you need?
You dirty freaks.
And this weekend,
san diego balboa.
Saturday night.
Me and Joey coco diaz,
aka mad flavor,
aka planet rock.
We're going to have a good time.
San diego.
And if the fucking apocalypse hits were
moments from Mexico.
So let's do tHis.
Thank you to onnit.com.
Use the code name,
rogan and save yourself 10 percent off
any and all supplements.
And we'll see fucking freaks next week.
We've got a lot,
a lot of fun next week lined up and most
likely will be a new studio.
Where do you live?
Mm mm.